what we're going to do in this video is
draw a connection between the idea of
opportunity cost of producing a good in
a certain country and comparative
advantage between countries in a certain
good
and
below right over here we have a chart
that shows the production possibility
curves for two different countries and
as we see in many economic models this
is a i would argue oversimplified model
but it helps us get some insights where
in each country workers can only produce
some combination of sneakers and
basketballs and to help us understand
this and to appreciate that you can see
this information in multiple ways let's
present this also as an output table
output
table which you will sometimes see and
from either the production bit
possibility curves or from the output
table we can calculate the opportunity
cost of shoes and the opportunity costs
of basketballs and then try to deduce
some things about comparative advantage
so in an output table we would look at
country a
and we would look at country b
and we would think about well what is
the max
and i'll just draw it what is the max
basketballs and this is all per worker
per day and we would also think what is
the max
shoes
shoes those look like socks but you get
the idea once again per worker per day
and so let me draw
a little chart here
so we can do that
and so what i'd like you to do is pause
this video and see if you can fill in
this chart what is the maximum
basketballs per worker per day in
country a and then country b and then do
the same thing for shoes
all right now let's work this together
so first in country a what is the
maximum number of basketballs well if in
country a they put all of their energy
into basketballs we are right over here
on the production possibilities curve
they can produce eight basketballs
and if on the other end of the curve
they put all of their energy into shoes
they would produce no basketballs and
six pairs of shoes we're assuming that
these are pairs of shoes that we're
talking about
six pairs of shoes
and similarly if we go to company if we
go to country b i keep saying company
instead of country if we go to country b
if we say what's the maximum number of
basketballs well if they put all their
energy into basketballs we get four
basketballs and no pairs of shoes so
that's four basketballs but then if they
put all the energy into pairs of shoes
they produce no basketballs they could
produce four pairs of shoes
and so it's as simple as that this
output table is just showing the
extremes from the production possibility
curves for these countries
now with the information both the output
table and these production possibility
curves let's calculate the opportunity
cost so let me set up another table and
let me just say this is going to be our
opportunity cost table oc not not orange
county opportunity costs and once again
it's going to be for country a
and country b
and we're going to think about the
opportunity cost of producing
basketballs and that's going to be in
terms of pairs of shoes and then the
opportunity costs for producing pairs of
shoes and that's going to be in terms of
basketballs and so let me set up another
table
and so i encourage you once again
pause this video and see if you can fill
in this table what is the opportunity
cost we'll start with what's the
opportunity cost for producing
basketballs in terms of shoes in country
a
all right well there's a couple of ways
to think about it imagine a world in
country where you're producing no
basketballs and you're producing six
pairs of shoes but then if you were to
increase the number of basketballs you
produce by eight
so if you add eight basketballs well
you're gonna give up six pairs of shoes
you see that right over here you give up
six pairs of shoes and so in country a
eight basketballs cost six shoes let me
write that down
so in country a
eight
basketballs and i'll just say b for
short cost
six
s
s is shoes for short or another way to
think about it if you divide both of
these by eight one basketball cost
six over eight shoes
all i did is eight basketballs cost six
shoes and one basketball is gonna cost
six divided by eight pairs of shoes and
so what is that going to be well six
over eight is the same thing as
three-fourths or three-fourths of a pair
of shoes so one basketball costs
three-fourths of a pair of shoes or we
could say that is 0.75
s where s is a pair of shoes for this is
my simplified notation and what about in
country b
well in country b if i go from no
basketballs to four basketballs
then i would have given up
four pairs of shoes i would have given
up four pairs of shoes so in country b
so in b
four
four basketballs
cost
four pairs of shoes or divide both by
four you could have a basketball one
basketball costs
one pair of shoes so a basket so a
basketball here in country b costs one
pair of shoes so one
pair of shoes s once again is a pair of
shoes
and you could have also gotten it from
this information here you could set up
an equation you could say look if i put
all of in country a
if i put so let's look at
this part right over here
you could say in country a
if i put all of my energy into
basketballs i could produce eight
basketballs but if i put that same
energy into shoes i could produce six
pairs of shoes
so with the same energy i could produce
either one of these and then if i want
the opportunity cost for basketballs i
divide both by eight and that's
essentially what i did over here
and i get a basketball
it costs 6 8 of a pair of shoes or 3 4
of a pair of shoes which is exactly what
i have over here
now let's do the opportunity cost for a
pair of shoes in either country
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could just view it as the
reciprocal or you could even go back to
this equation right over here if we are
in country
a
we would say
six shoes if we put all our energy in
shoes we could produce six of them or
six pairs of shoes i should say and if
we put all of our energy into
basketballs we could produce eight
basketballs but if you divide
by six you get per pair of shoes
and so per each pair of shoes the energy
to produce one pair of shoes is
equivalent to the energy to produce 8 6
of a basketball and 8 6 is the same
thing as four thirds of a basketball and
if we wanted to write it as a decimal
just for simplicity or maybe to make it
easier to compare we would say that this
is approximately 1.33 obviously the
threes just keep going on it repeats
forever but approximately 1.33
basketballs is the cost of producing a
shoe and the opportunity cost of
producing a shoe in country a
1.33
basketballs
and what about in country b
well in country b we could set up a
similar type of equation where the same
energy for four shoes i could produce
four basketballs and that's essentially
what we set up right over here on the
left you divide both sides by four the
energy of a shoe is equal to the energy
of a basketball and or i should say the
energy of a pair of shoes is equal to
the energy of making a basketball so the
opportunity cost of making a pair of
shoes is equal to one basketball
so now we're ready to draw the
connection
given the opportunity costs that we have
calculated
what country has the comparative
advantage in basketballs
pause this video and try to figure it
out so now let's look at the opportunity
cost of producing a basketball in either
country
in country a it's each basketball costs
a worker three-fourths of a pair of
shoes one country b it costs them a
whole pair of shoes
so country a actually has a lower
opportunity cost of producing
basketballs and so it has the
comparative advantage here
comparative
advantage
and then if we look at shoes it goes the
other way around
country a has an opportunity cost of one
and one-third basketballs for every pair
of shoes while country b has an
opportunity cost of only one basketball
per pair of shoes so it has a lower
opportunity cost and this one actually
might be a little bit counter-intuitive
because if you look on the shoe axis
right over here country a has the
absolute advantage in producing shoes a
worker per day in country a can produce
six pairs of shoes while a worker in
country b can only produce four pairs of
shoes but even though country a has the
absolute advantage it would actually
make sense for country a to focus on
basketballs while country b focuses on
shoes and in the next video we'll see
how they can trade with each other to
get to a scenario that is beyond their
production possibility curves and why
com why focusing on your comparative
advantage at least in this theoretical
very simplified world makes sense